ou Thomas euh j'ai juste une petite
question que je me pose depuis longtemps
il se passe quoi si quelqu'un meurt dans
l'ISS ouais alors ça commence direct
avec les ouais les petites questions
légères si quelqu'un meurt dans l'ISS
c'est qu'il s'est passé quelque chose de
de tellement énorme nous on est testé
médicalement nous tout est testé donc tu
vois il y a pas de procédure standard
mais eu on a quand même des des éléments
de de réaction tu vois on a un
défibrilateur on a euh des intraosseuses
des intraveineuses on a tout ce qui faut
rait pour réagir à une situation
d'urgence après une fois que la
situation est finie et que j'espère que
non le le gars ou la fille est vraiment
plus de ce monde bon bah là il faudrait
je sais pas tellement ce qu'on ferait
mais mais c'est pas encore tellement
prévu ouais